colombians came out in mass to choose
the country's congressional lawmakers
and presidential candidates on sunday in
a vote that indicated a significant
political shift in this historically
conservative country
discontent in anger against traditional
parties and their neoliberal economic
policies boosted progressive and
independent candidates in the senate in
the house of representatives
we've had some rough times in the last
few years so i hope that this election
will bring some positive results and our
country will change
i think people are absolutely done tired
and worn out that the expectations as
citizens never materialized
unfortunately our old political class
has always played us
as leftist centrists and right-wing
coalitions tallied votes in their
respective primaries the night's clear
winner was gustavo petro a leftist
senator and former guerrilla who
received more than double the votes of
his closest rival right-wing candidate
federico gutierrez we saw a contraction
of the right wing
and a growth both from the centrist
parties and most significantly from the
left but what this means is that there
will be no single party or no single uh
political bloc with a majority in
congress for the next four years but it
also opens the possibility that a
leftist could win the presidency for the
first time in history something that has
right-wing voters on edge
i'm worried we need to defend democracy
on top of everything we can't allow a
leftist in power that's not convenient
for the country doesn't know how to
govern and is not transparent i fear
entrepreneurs will lose the ability to
hire people will not be able to afford a
home
fearing the possibility of fraud and
political violence more than 2 500
national and international observers
were deployed across the country
while voting was mostly peaceful two
soldiers died in bomb attacks in rural
areas where voters were called to choose
special representatives among victims of
the country's long civil conflict
what's clear is that this is a night to
remember for the supporters of gustavo
petra in his leftist coalition
an historic result that confirms that he
will be the candidate to beat in the
upcoming presidential elections in may
alessandro
al jazeera bogota